so when i said that mike flynn was back
in the news and his
advocating for a military coup in the
united states was likely protected by
the first amendment many people said
well wait a minute
but what about the fact that he is a
former military officer couldn't he be
punished under the uniform code of
military justice
and the answer is maybe but he probably
should not be first of all
yes it is possible for retired military
officers to be punished under the
uniform code of military justice but
it's unlikely that those laws are going
to withstand first amendment scrutiny
it's actually an issue that is currently
on appeal law professor steve vladick is
heading the charge to try and overturn
the current case law on this and they
stand a good chance
of succeeding so this is one of those
cases where under current law it might
theoretically be possible
but if that was ever challenged and went
up to the supreme court there's a good
chance that might be overruled so
we will in fact see this issue in court